So you don't want to go play Ping-Pong?
It's fine.
Let's talk about what kind of restaurant you should be picking.
So, obviously you have to pick something that you can actually have a conversation in.
So, if you're gonna go to a restaurant, find something kind of middle-of-the-road, you know.
You wanna make sure your date feels comfortable,...
...but at the same time, you probably shouldn't be taking her to McDonald's for the first date.
So, somewhere in the middle, there lies a nice little Italian,...
...or whatever place that you can actually have a conversation and connect at.
I think that's the biggest thing.
It needs to feel romantic, and it needs to feel like you can have an intimate conversation.
Don't go anywhere too fancy.
You're not putting on your tuxedo on the first date.
You're not gonna make your date feel uncomfortable if she shows up in jeans and heels.
So, you need to find something that's kind of middle-of-the-road,...
...a bunch of different outfits would work for it.
Not that you are guys are thinking of this, but we are.
Anything above a chain restaurant and below, like the Four Seasons is pretty much doable for a first date.
You need to have a conversation.
You need to be able to hear each other.
So yeah, a little Italian restaurant where you can bring your own bottle of wine...
...and maybe having a little story about how you picked it out, just to give something to talk about...
...or something that kind of lends itself to a good environment.
You want it to feel intimate and romantic but not too over-the-top.